please to have here in our New York
studio for the first time normally talk
with this gentleman when he's out in Los
Angeles where his beloved Dodgers almost
pulled it off the man who plays
detective James Gordon now currently in
season four on Fox of Gotham Ben
McKenzie good to see you sir yeah you
bet
so um do you Seiken Dolan sazon your
Dodgers it was right that in there right
it was right there I just finally came
out of mourning yesterday this is the
first day I'm not wearing black yeah it
was uh it was a great series
I got to see Game four in Houston right
which is one we won which was so that my
experience of it my personal experience
I thought was very positive
yeah I guess that that was the the game
for where Alex would start against yes
the colors yes and it was like the way
the series should have gone if you're a
Dodger fan right like we would had a
good start kept him in on our going four
innings four or five innings came to the
bullpen
we got enough runs we got ahead we'll
put and close it down and that was like
oh this is this is how the rest of its
gonna be right yeah that's what my
colors start a game three and then he
started Game seven eventually so you
didn't go to that game three where you
Darvish got lit up and you were not that
game five where that game was Kershaw's
to have with a four and three run lead
and then went totally off the rails
heartbreak I know right and then seven
was like such a just flick in general
kind of I kept waiting for the Dodgers
to do something and it never happened
just couldn't do it I give all the
credit the world to the Astros what an
unbelievable team effort I mean they
were incredible and so the Dodgers too
though I mean it was in you know to 100
win teams going at it Hotel two of it
was just named MVP of the American
League last night amazing and he you
know he's well well deserved now you
have your you're more of a Dallas guy
because I know you're from Texas from
Boston you're from Austin which is sort
of equidistant from Houston and Dallas
so does that make you Houston Dallas
agnostic pretty much exactly I mean you
know the baseball games I would go to or
the Longhorn baseball games the
University of Texas which had a which
has a good program and definitely did
one anybody anybody who you remember
that played there that one a playing in
the major league oh yeah yes but now I'm
blanking on
a couple of pitchers who made it there
yeah oh man yeah the guy named Roger
Clemens
so when were you there so Brockman can
look um oh yeah
Rahman uh when we lived there until 90
no until 2 97 okay look sort of like 80s
and 90s um good program college baseball
a different beast
obviously you're right you're sort of
you know maybe sure I know I went to I
remember I was you know I went to
Michigan yeah and I covered the Michigan
baseball team
now Big Ten baseball teams don't have it
like teams down in Texas or on the west
coast cuz you know gets kind of cold
from time to time occasionally but there
was a pitcher named Jim Abbott who
pitched for the for the Yankees
eventually and obviously the the angels
who was born with one hand yes and I
remember being in the stadium a small
Stadium in Ann Arbor that was filled
with fans and then tons of scouts to
watch him play where he threw like a
three-hit shutout in the first game and
in the second game cuz they're a bunch
of national league scouts there they put
him up there to hit to show that he
could be hit in the major leagues as
well and he laced he laced an opposite
field triple and I will never truly to
this day been one of the greatest
baseball moments I've ever witnessed
it's really extraordinary members I
remember sitting there covering it and I
was right behind and there was a scout
that was holding up the jugs gun
pitchers and he took he put the jugs gun
away in his his suitcase which kind of
looked like a pulp fiction type suitcase
it didn't glow when it opened but it had
less an Francisco Giants logo on it I'm
like okay we got National League Scouts
here and he was incredible that's
amazing lacing a triple on a centennial
opposite field together did you find
anybody in the in the program Houston
Street
yes Houston Street I remember he was he
was pretty JP Howell mmm-hmm those are
guys right there yeah yeah Houston
Street who Stubbs Ben Mackenzie here on
the Rich Eisen show from Gotham what do
you think about this long orange season
that had was filled with so much
football
you know of German now we're getting
we're getting better we're in the games
we're not getting blown out at least not
not regularly
and we're making it competitive and at
times and winning the games we should
win or at least most of them we got a
ways to go but I like I like how he's
he's getting him to focus the defense is
solid ironically it's all wrong yes that
game against USC was phenomenal it was
that was a hell of a game he was and it
was kind of a nice little throwback for
you yeah
did you notice cuz again here you're
busy man again playing Jim Gordon and
Gotham did you see that the USC media
notes for that game right okay had USC
for no all time yes yes I did see that
did see that there's my laws they said
we were told that we had to remove
everything from that season wins and
lost
Rock ate them right Wow I love that I
love the excuse that like we cheated
there for our losses don't count as well
they said the n-c-double-a said that
they had a vacate the entirety you know
so so so so I mean we may have talked
about this before I forgive me but I was
living in LA in the 2005 season and
bought eight 50-yard line
tickets from my family hanging out yeah
well you were you shooting Southland I
was shooting yes it was either yeah it
must have in the OC must have been
thirty third or fourth year the OC sure
and I mean cuz this was you know this
hadn't happened in decades for us and
and certainly not in my lifetime my
consciousness so you know we had to do
it and it was right there I was right in
LA so we had 850 or online seats and we
watched the end of the game of our lives
and Vince Young running in the end zone
and and and to sit there amongst the USC
fans who have got to be some of those
smug self-satisfied just great cuz I
don't want you to see them guys enjoyed
that ly nerds postgame we're still the
better team you know that kind of thing
you're like you guys just oh we beat you
I don't you in your own not according to
us exactly exactly
that was great I mean every
but he was pointing out well hold on a
minute the game notes are normally very
accurate animation department coming out
of South Central Los got a trumpian
memory house guys and yet hey they said
they were just found that you're just
following or they were trumpeter and
this ground we have covered before but I
want to hit it again here because the
Saints are now seven and two and you go
back in the day with Drew Brees correct
yeah you you played what would we play
middle school football together we went
to st. Andrews middle school in Austin
Texas okay he was he was definitely a
quarterback and yes he was and and great
he hadn't actually I don't think he'd
started playing tackle at all until high
school and then we went to different
high schools it's amazing what he has
become unbelievable and what a career
and what a lovely have you crossed paths
with him at all no now we have enough we
got to at some point I got out of reach
out to him yeah I mean there's seven and
two right now it's amazing seven wins in
a row and he does not seem to be
anything but first-ballot awesome still
yeah pushing forty with four kids to I
believe I believe he's got four of them
I know I'll like sit down on the couch
to watch him play and hurt myself that's
right and he's pushing forty uh Ben
McKenzie here on the Rich Eisen show
how's everything going on the on Gotham
season for that is amazing yeah season
four I am now a captain okay so that's
you're no longer a detective James I am
no longer detective James Gordon as of a
couple weeks ago now we're now captain
at what point is do you foresee Gotham
covering your time when you finally
ascend to the role that well you know
that is that is a possibility to be
commissioner in the next couple of years
seems a little tricky so when hat props
have to have to spool out but you never
know apparently Commissioner might be
available in the National Football
League
yeah exactly I'm not sure I want that
job you sure you don't want that one to
figure although so what would be tougher
would be corralling Gotham City or you
know I yeah boy that's that's Detroit
against to some interesting territory
perhaps I should I'm trying to I'm
already second-guessing asking the
question
yeah their their meeting was right
across the street from where I live at
the Conrad the other day when they were
discussing the movie national and it'd
you knock on the exactly just sort of
exactly sold up a sign outside yeah yeah
no you know it's it's it's it's
unfortunate that the oxygen has been
sucked out of the room to a certain
degree and and you know both both things
should in my mind be able to exist
simultaneously which is players ie
citizens in this great democracy
expressing their opinion however they
see fit as our Constitution allows lest
we forget and also we can enjoy a
football game right it seemed like we
could do both of these and also uh like
I do when my kids are at a game we stand
and put our hand over our heart right
and that's the way that I conduct myself
during the national anthem right but
I've had a different American experience
than the players who are not attending
exactly the national and yeah and we can
have a conversation about it still enjoy
some football and try to make this world
a better place I would hope so
teni that sounds you know rational I
know we're living in highly irrational
please we're living in quite sort of
polarized strange times it's it's a
shame that even football has gotten
infected and so how old are your kids
four and a little less than two I know
so there's a lot more football to come
yeah the four year old said the other
day he liked the Yankees we're four year
old sounds like what he said it also
likes the Dodgers to it's so so here's
just least there's a little bit of I
married into a New England family right
I'm from here in New York City right so
I don't need to tell you you're a man
you're you're a man of the world you
you've got a indeed you've got a
beautiful spouse okay okay you should do
uh it's all about compromise indeed been
corrected so here we go uh when the
Patriots onesies began arriving at the
house all right
it was okay as a guy who grew up loving
the Jets yeah if I in the Tom Brady era
tried to make a Stan
in here child services would come down
right and plus I'm a Michigan Wolverine
so rooting for Tom Brady sure
big-time thumbs up sure I'm a New York
Knick fan the Celtics bibs arrived at
the house and am i okay the Knicks are
run by the worst owner in sports true
and this is pre porzingis right and they
start rooting for Isiah Thomas is now on
the Cavs I'm like that guy's aces not a
problem right
Red Sox books stuff that monster showed
a red line red line red line to the
point where my daughter's middle name is
Mattingly Wow how did that conversation
well it was like we had two boys my wife
said you know someone's missing she was
correct I'm gonna go I'm like wow two is
already a lot three handful so she's
like here's the deal we try for the girl
we get the girl you'd name the girl oh
my okay we try for the girl we get the
girl my naming rights are demoted to
middle name well you were you gonna go
were you gonna go Mattingly first name
Don's a great name for a girl sure
absolutely just the Nate middle name
demoted Mattingly hey you know what I
think that that is that's a good
marriage right so that's a screwed up
kid okay for the rest of her life you
know that that is but if Monica has no
sports dog in the hunt yes and your
child wants to root for something other
than your team yes yeah that one I don't
have any roadmap for you on that front
yeah I mean you know he's he's he is
saying both Yankees and Dodgers so I'm I
know I know
look but you're bicoastal and it's the
long game yeah and you know what he's
for we got it's a lot of years well
check out a Gotham again on fox
Thursdays at 8:00 Eastern Time currently
in season four at
and underscore Mackenzie on Twitter good
to see you here sir you bet as always
Ben McKenzie here on this edition the
Rich Eisen show you four more Rich Eisen
show tuned to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Rich Eisen show
app